behind the glass a murderers rapists
violent offenders but unlike England
overcrowding isn't a problem here in
Holland there aren't enough criminals to
fill the cells all the doors are open
now so prisoners can't walk freely
within this secure area they're all open
they're all open yet unlocked doors
surround part of the wing and every new
inmate is given keys to his own South
it's my goal my wardrobe when I close my
jacket my bench John has been in door
jack jail for two years and shows us
around the epic shadow of his own toilet
there's no that's Mike everything's
focused on preparing for life outside
yes vidrio
British eyes this may not look like
punishment but the Dutch say it works
what does it mean to you being able to
come and go give you a little bit more
responsibility and it's not to get bored
to ask God every time to open the door
for you do you think it keeps people a
bit happier yeah yeah yeah the Dutch
used to have one of the highest
imprisonment rates in Western Europe
behind Britain but jail was expensive
and wasn't stopping reoffending so they
looked for alternative punishments Karen
is the governor here this is the cross
so this prisoners on she tells me
prisoner numbers have plunged and how
many prisoners do you have here 336 we
can have 472 now hole wings are deserted
so you're not full moon awful you can
look inside completely empty empty in
Holland we take different sentences at
this moment so we choose for minor
offenses to give the people fines or
community service services or tags and
in prison we focus on rehabilitation so
that's why they stay out of prison and
don't come back
as in England downstairs prisoners have
to work but no overcrowding means by law
everyone's guaranteed a job staff say it
helps rehabilitation and reduces tension
do you think it makes them behave better
keeping them busy hmm
yes yes they are quieter on average a
third of Dutch cells are now unused more
controversially nineteen prisons have
closed in the last few years
others rent space to Norway in Belgium
so this cell usually houses six people
it now stands empty as does the entire
wing behind me and it raises the
question as to whether the UK's under
pressure and frequently overcrowded
prisons can learn from the Dutch for
many recent riots approved English jails
of Fame the government's promising more
than a billion pounds of improvements
but some British politicians say the
time has come to consider Dutch
alternatives to prison reoffending costs
about eighteen and a half billion pounds
but to our economy so adopting a model
along the lines of the Dutch perhaps
that is actually going to save money in
terms of the amount of prison places the
Dutch system isn't without its faults or
its critics but our overfilled prisons
are failing to rehabilitate many while
they're inside or drastically reduce
offending when they're out so maybe it's
time to reconsider what justice really
means
Siobhan Robbins Sky News in the
Netherlands